Guten Morgen Linus.
Guten Morgen Tim.
Aber ich habe gehört das Mobilfunk tatsächlich Strahlen aussendet damit habe ich aber jetzt nicht gerechnet.
Sag das bloß nicht den Leuten in kleßen-görne.
Logbuch Netzpolitik Nummer 279 vom 13. Dezember 2018 das Jahr,
wird an Aufregung nicht ärmer geht aber trotzdem langsam zu Ende immerhin wird es jetzt später früher.
Nee später Dunk.
Später noch einen Kongress geben.
Das auch aber es wird dir schon später.
Später dunkel ist schon Sommersonnenwende oder wie das heißt Winterwende.
Nee aber es näher wird gerade in dieser Übergangsphase wo es auch früher dunkel wird morgens früher hell wird morgens also der Tag fest ich fange noch mal.
Wenn die Uhren vor oder zurückgestellt.
Wie gestern also die Tage sind noch nicht länger geworden.
Aber die.
Aber die Nächte schon mal da.
Ab aber die Nächte fangen später an so jetzt habe ich ihm eins wenn der Kongress das wird sowieso wieder alles gut,
das ist ja auch das ist ja auch im diskordische Kalender der entscheidende Zeitpunkt nicht also das wissen ja auch viele Leute nicht dass der diskordische Kalender das Jahr so in fünf Teile aufteilt,
und am Ende des Kalenderjahres endet ja sozusagen die Phase Fonsi after Mass.
Die Nachwirkungen der Auflösung der Explosion der Bürokratie Alters und dann wenn der Kongress vorbei ist beginnt das Chaos die erste Saison.
So ist es jedes Jahr immer wieder ein nicht enden wollender Cyclos und wir sind mitten in ihm drin.
Wenn nicht im Zyklus mit drin ist ist aber kleßen-görne ne.
Jack Gleeson gerne.
Was habe ich gesagt halt an deiner Funkzelle fest als sie als sie den da hingestellt wurde dieser Anhänger ne was habe ich prognostiziert was wurde hier prophezeit.
Ist gerade wenig kommunizieren was auch gerade beim Rathaus angerufen und dabei auch nichts.
Überall wird mit Ach und Krach im Internet die Nummer des kleßen-görne Rathaus aufgefunden weil ich fragen wollte.
Warum wollte da mal bei der Regierung nachfragen warum wir da ihre Leute nicht unter Kontrolle haben.
Es hat sich tatsächlich.
Muss gleich kurz noch erklären für Leute dieses nicht.
Bläst gerne weil dieses dieses kleine.
Gallische Dorf am Rande Berlins das bisher noch nicht von der Infrastruktur erschlossen wurde und mit großem Tamtam wurde ihre.
Der Mobilfunk Infrastruktur.
Da die haben doch du siehst doch auf google maps Google Maps dazu auch noch Sickergruben im Garten haben.
Ich suche auf jeder die ganze Zeit die Stromleitung die habe ich noch nicht gefunden.
Es ist nicht erschlossen die wie heißt diese Insel wo wir gerade auch noch geschaut haben.
Citadel.
Thomas sollte gar nicht hinfahren nachlesen gerade mit Mobilfunk auftaucht kann es sein das soll wird mit Giftpfeil beworfen.
Die sind hartnäckig also dieses dieses Dorf.
Wo man ganz stolz
aus Berlin mit Infrastrukturminister mit eigenem Bussen mit WLAN also WLAN hatten sie auch an im WLAN war halt nur kein Internet dran hingefallen ist
hübschen deutschen Diesel Citypark Autogas in das Dorf und haben gesagt herzlichen Glückwunsch. Selloana die Funkzelle,
die hatte Zelda weil sie auf einem Anhänger stand und ich habe das halt ich habe da er schon den Verrat gewittert und ich habe gesagt.
Halte daran fest die habt ihr nicht lange und der mir groß gefeiert und im Juli und dann.
Musste jetzt brauchen wir nur noch die Baugenehmigungen dann können wir da eine Funkzelle errichten,
ja das muss man sich vorstellen wie so ein Maibaum was ist da errichtet,
dann kommt auch das ganze Dorf dann tanzen die drum und machen selfies so und jetzt esse jetzt hat sich aber leider eine Bürgerbewegung gegründet,
dagegen die also diesen Funkmast Bau verhindern wollen und damit steht das jetzt erstmal wieder in den Sternen.
Das ist sehr interessant.
Die Deutsche Telekom hat bekanntgegeben dass sie da der hat damals bekannt gegeben dass sie sich diese Errichtung 350 €,
pro Einwohner kosten lassen würde.
Das sei natürlich nicht wirtschaftlich haben sie damals durchblicken lassen naja also
ja du musst ein bisschen warten bis das bis sich das rentiert aber so ist das eben mit Infrastruktur Wasserphase was du nicht hast,
hast du nicht und in kleßen-görne haben sie hat sich jetzt ernsthaft eine Bürgerbewegung.
Mobilfunkausbau na ja wegen der Strahlen.
Meinst du also Naturschutz Auflagen werden auch als Hindernis genannt es gibt Gemeinden die damit werben strahlenfrei zu sein.
Das ist sehr schön.
Das ist wirklich mal ein ganz neues Tourismus fällt was man erschließen kann 100% strahlenfrei 100% merkbefreit.
Und.
Kommen Sie zu uns wenn sie sowieso schon.
Unten in störten Barcode offen trinkt oder trinkwasserflasche das ist auch sehr wichtig Tim das ist wichtig.
Du ich mache immer immer.
Die Kristall die Kristallgitter von deinem Wasser werden sonst vergiftet oder so.
Mein Wasser kann ja nichts passieren dass es beliebt.
Was macht was sagt man deckelmann dahin nein wenn man da jetzt jemanden hin schickt der die ein bisschen missioniert musst du Angst haben dass sie den mit dem Diesel überfahren oder sowas.
Ja oder wie auf den Zettel hinkommen die damit gefallen aus ihren Häusern raus
durch einen Moment überlegt ob man da nicht einfach mein Kind machen sollte und das damit der Internet Infrastruktur einfach so zu regeln einfach Glasfaser einbuddeln und liegen lassen aber.
Wenn die dann so so also weiß nie vielleicht wollen ja auch mit der Außenwelt kann nicht kommuniziert.
Offensichtlich wollen die das nicht ne gehen nicht ans Telefon.
Da könnte man dann auch für.
Wir unberührt bleiben ich finde das auch in Ordnung also dann muss man sich halt darauf einigen dann sollen die halten Strich in Sand machen.
Das wäre wahrscheinlich auch dann für die Bundesregierung ganz gut wenn man einfach mehrere so eine Gebiete ausweisen könnte dann könnte man diese Zahl aus der versorgungsfläche rausnehmen.
Dann sind das keine weißen Flächen mehr entdeckt.
Das sind schwarze Gebiete.
Bestell mir dann einfach so ein Schild hin hier endet Achtung sie verlassen den den Mobilfunk technisch erschlossenen Sektor.
Da fällt mir noch heute so ein alter Mythos ein und falls irgendwelche.
Sie verlassen sie verlassen den digitalen Sektor.
Da gibt's nämlich also das wollte schon immer mal überprüfen weil das weiß ich nicht ob ich ob ich die Wahrheit erzählt aber mir wurde es mal so zugetragen dass man den
an den Grenzen von Ostberlin also den Grenzen nicht zu Westberlin sondern zu Everest der DDR Schilder stand auf den EDV stand.
Ich weiß nicht warum ich weiß nicht ob das so war aber es wurde mir so erzählt von Austin Bürgern.
Bevor der gemeinhin als Ende der Versorgung falls er nicht mehr so.
Schützemann dass er dann eigentlich auch sehe das sein wenn die Bundesregierung von EDV-Lösungen spricht sollte man schon sehr skeptisch werden.
Stell mir so eine Situation vor na also steht großes Schild über now leaving.
Belvedere Digitals actor,
in in englisch russisch französisch ne und dann eines Tages stehen die sich dann so gegenüber wie am Checkpoint Charlie so der Bautrupp der deine Funkzelle errichten will,
und die kleinen.
Dadada digitate natia.
Görner Kämpfer rudimentär bekleidet mit Pfeil und Bogen.
Und dann muss einer nachgeben und dann wird das in den Geschichtsbüchern stehen.
Assassin in um des lieben Frieden willens man sieht denn der Kreuzzug digitalien abgewehrt wurde.
Die Sendung Gerät langsam an dem Punkt wo wünscht sich zum nächsten Thema vorangehens.
Meiste Themen lass uns einfach Fassung Fassung.
Nicht los ne wir träumen auf jeden Fall nach wie vor von digitalen Weihnachten für uns kommen die Daten Elche und ziehen den großen Kaffee mit Datenpaketen dieses dann endlich unter den Tannenbaum gelegt werden.
Ja vor allem weil unsere Daten heraus kleßen-görne wieder abkommandiert werden die sind offenbar nicht wegkommen.
Nee die schicken wir jetzt alle nach Leipzig.
Wir waren gestern im Kino tippen.
Ampel guckt.
Genau wie letzte Woche angekündigt haben wir uns all creatures welcome angeschaut in nötiger Atmosphäre weil da waren dann viele Leute aus wie man so schön sagt dem Umfeld nicht nur aber auch.
Aus dem internet du hast ja gesehen ne zuerst mal meine ich also gesehen hab.
Ich habe den in in dem finalen Schnitt in der Form das erste Mal vollständig gesehen genau weil ich weiß nicht die Version die letzte Mal letztes Jahr auf dem Kongress da lief war die.
Der wird wiederum nicht gesehen ich weiß nicht genau welche.
Ich auch nicht genau deswegen kann ich nicht alle sofern was erstmal und insofern kann ich sagen war nicht ganz angenehmen,
angetan du hast ja noch die eine oder andere Frage diskutiert im Nachgang und konnte dann eigentlich mit deiner Sichtweise,
der konnte ich gut nachvollziehen also was du da so zu.
Was war denn meine Sichtweise.
Na das also erstmal das ganze ein sehr emotionaler Blick ist auf die Chaos Events,
das da sehr viel rüberkommt dass es auch das hat glaube ich dann Daniel auch gesagt dann Domscheit-Berg bei auch noch,
mit kurz auf dem Treppchen dass er schnell wieder klar wird,
das ist nicht so den einen Kongress und nicht so dass eine Camp gibt das so viel passiert auf diesem Veranstaltung so und also Unfassbare Dichte von Dingen und Geschehnissen und Wahnsinn und verrückten Leuten und crazy Aktion
dass du wahrscheinlich dass 10 Personen 10 unterschiedlich vollständig unterschiedliche Erlebnisse haben,
auf dieser Veranstaltung un.
Das auch der Kongress was er für mehr an einer Stelle auch zeigt sich auch für Leute öffnet die,
ganz andere Bedürfnisse haben konkret kommt ja da diese Sicht der Autisten die sich ja seit einigen Jahren,
vermehrt und gruppiert auf dem Kongress wiederfinden kommt dazu Sprache.
Und das habe ich auch von Anfang an schon immer sehr angetan diese Aussage mit dir kann ich einfach,
sein hier wird das anders sein auch einfach akzeptiert hier ist es in gewisser Hinsicht sogar noch einmal anders zu sein Buch,
berührend gab auch ein paar Wortmeldungen aus dem Publikum die so in diese Richtung ging also.
Das war du sprichst jetzt für psychisch am Ende des oder Richtung Ende des Films gibt's im das Interview mit dem Jan,
der darüber über seine Erfahrung auf dem Kongress spricht und der übrigens auch dieses Jahr
dass dieses Team C3 Audi zum ersten Mal jetzt,
Amazon also ins Leben indiziert leitet so ein bisschen als weil das ja immer alles sehr sehr flache Hierarchie,
der da gerade die in izi Haupt Initiative übernommen hat haben wir jetzt auch auf help ccc.de übernommen vor einigen Tagen,
und die haben also das Hilfsangebot irgendwie primär geht's darum dass dieser Kongress eben überlasten überfordern sein kann und das
da ihr daneben von Autisten für Autisten Unterstützung geleistet wird,
Ruheräume angeboten werden dass sie in bestimmten Situationen helfen die ohne Unterstützung vielleicht nicht gehen würden beraten aber auch natürlich bei Leuten die sich vielleicht,
zum für das Thema Autismus interessieren so ist doch eine ganz coole Sache.
Ja oder wie es im Film dann anfangs und so einfache Lösung mit ja hier mein Engel Job überfordert mich einfach gerade zu viel unterschiedliche Dinge zufällig zu viel Menschen zu viel was auch immer.
Mama was.
Schönes Ding also ich war mir war selber am Anfang nicht so ganz klar wohin die Reise hier geht,
der Film versucht gar nicht so sehr stark am Anfang zu kontextualisieren so nach dem Motto,
Hallo wir kommen zusammen Film wir reden jetzt über die Events des Chaos Computer Clubs und es gibt folgende und dies und das also es gibt da keine großen Einleitung sondern wird einfach von vorne rein bis zum Ende eigentlich auch durchgehend
eigentlich immer nur in diese sich permanent im Ping Pong zwischen Kongress und Camp befindliche Atmosphäre eingetaucht und
tritt irgendwie alle 20 Sekunden wieder eine andere Welt ein.
Und in gewisser Hinsicht gelingt es dem Film diese und diese erstaunlichen Bandbreite diese erstaunliche kulturelle und diese erstaunliche Erlebnis Bandbreite diese Veranstaltung,
mitsichbringen ganz gut darzustellen insofern.
Wann ist die Präsentation auf dem Kongress 29.12.
29.12 im Abendprogramm.
Genau und dann wird dieser Film auch.
Released denn er ist ja komplett unter Creative Commons und das sogar noch etwas mehr als wir vielleicht beide vorher dachten ich weiß nicht kannst du dieses Lied.
Mit dem Greyhound culture erkannte ich oder welches Detail weiß.
Ja genau das also nicht nur der Film in seinem fertigen Schnitt veröffentlicht wird sondern es wird auch,
der Film in seinen Komponenten release also man kann sich quasi den Filmen auch Track für Track schnappen wie es da genau mit Daten vom alten aussieht weiß ich nicht auf jeden Fall
wird wenn Dinge möglich sein wie,
eine Übersetzungen andere Sprachen die so noch nicht unterstützt sind Untertitel natürlich sowieso aber es geht noch einen Schritt weiter auch das komplette Rohmaterial,
ob sowas eine Größenordnung von 70 Stunden wird auch seinen Weg ins Netz finden was dann wiederum die Möglichkeit bietet aus diesem Material auch,
ganz anderen Blick noch mal auf das Geschehen zu eröffnen keine Ahnung ob sich da jemand in die Bresche werfen wird aber ist auf jeden Fall möglich,
hier aus einem Dokumentation Projekt noch andere Sachen zu machen
wann hattest du das da ganz zufrieden mit sie meint sie hat ihr Ding gemacht dass es quasi aus dem Material das was sie machen wollte und wenn andere Leute aus dem Material was anderes machen möchten dann bitteschön.
Finde ich eine spannende spannendes Beispiel dafür dass also der Film erscheint dann oder der steht unter einer Creative Commons-Lizenz ja das heißt der ist,
ihn zu teilen weiterzugeben zu kopieren und so weiter ist erlaubt erwünscht und dass es daran kann man
jetzt löschen Sie doch jeder ist dann das ist daneben ein gemeinfreie Filme aber dadurch dass sie jetzt auch noch
Kaisers gesamte Rohmaterial veröffentlicht wird der Film quasi so so Nordens ostfilm ne also du kannst den jetzt kannst du ihn jetzt umschneiden gibt's in verschiedenen Versionen kannst den verlängern
und.
Du hast nicht nur prinzipiell die Erlaubnis Teile daraus zu verwenden zu verwenden oder kriegst auch Teile die nicht da drin waren das wird allerdings nicht bis nicht nicht mehr in diesem Jahr noch passieren sondern diese create your own culture,
Plattform wird wohl eher so in Richtung Sommer also wahrscheinlich beim Camp dann oder so zu dem Zeitpunkt verlieren einfach diese 70 Stunden Videomaterial kannst ja nicht einfach dampfen weil,
in der Soße trotzdem noch unseren schönen Anforderungen hinsichtlich Anonymisierung Verpixelung von Gesichtern und so weiter genügen
und das muss eben alles gesichtet und sortiert sein wenn es veröffentlicht wird,
das ist natürlich ein Mammutprojekt das ist noch mal eine ganz ganz ganz krasse Sache und das macht diesen Film natürlich auch zu einem.
In sich auf eine gewisse Weise einzigartigen Projekt das ist,
das ist so viel mit liefert mir ist nicht bekannt das habe ich ja gestern auch gesagt dass sowas jemand anders schon mal gemacht hätte kann sein,
jetzt vielleicht geben in diesem Fall aber natürlich auch noch verbunden mit dieser ganzen Idee der Filmförderung und so,
Rosanna sagt das sollte eigentlich nicht was besonderes sein sondern völlig normal die will der Film wurde ja mit öffentlichen Geldern gefördert warum wird dann die Daten mit.
Dass die damit geförderten Kulturprodukte nicht auch irgendwann der öffentlichen Hand übergeben.
Wieso der Öffentlichkeit genau ein genau,
so sehen wir das natürlich auch und mal gucken ob wir da mit diesem Projekt auch was anstoßen können wer jetzt noch schnell ist,
am 14 und am 16. Dezember gibt es noch public Screenings in Saarbrücken in Hamburg in Unna am 14 am 16 noch mal in Unna,
und dann gibt's noch weitere Screenings dann im Januar da findet ihr im Kalender auf der Webseite all creatures welcome. Nett dort wird dann auch der Film ist für dich,
irgendwann zum Download verfügbar sein schätze mal wenn er beim Kongress dann released ist geht es dann auch sehr schnell in die Welt und dann.
Viel Spaß dabei Feedback gehabt.
Ja hatten wir.
Wieder was falsch gesagt weil ich das nicht dass dass du.
Na wir haben uns über den Digital Marxismus unterhalten ich weiß es nicht mehr ganz genau wer sich hier zum Thema Eisenbahn von uns beiden geäußert hat wenn wir einfach mal beide die Schuld.
Nein ich finde das was du.
Okay gut dann mach ich das dann bist du einfach für alles andere Schuld also es,
kommentierte Christoph
Christoph Stein das war nicht Karl Marx sondern Fürst von Bismarck der in Deutschland die Eisenbahn verstaatlicht hat die Eisenbahngesellschaften waren nicht in der Lage ein vernünftiges flächendeckendes Schienennetz aufzubauen die Situation war ähnlich wie bei den heutigen Netzen an,
schon fit noch in zu Decke ist dürfte Tipps schossen bei seiner Bewerbung zum Kanzler auch durchaus fördern
wenn es wenn es sich nicht als Margrit max ist dann als Anhänger Bismarcks presentiert meine Stimme hat er auf jeden Fall und Ines wird auch ein ganz brauchbaren digital Minister abgeben na dann,
läuft das doch.
Alles klar dann dann machen wir das so dann dann editiert du das bitte noch mal hier Bewerbung. Md noch einmal ändert nach dem Prinzip bis der Bismarck ist der Bismarck ist Pritlove.
Ja ich bewerbe mich ja auch nicht zum Kanzler ich will wieder Kanzlerin werden weil wir jetzt gesehen haben möchte eine Wette gewonnen.
Das auch schon der Geld für bekommen oh ja das hat weh getan.
Ja knapp aufjedenfall AKK jetzt die nächste potenzielle Kanzlerkandidaten bleibt bleibt jetzt einfach auch bei Frauen finde ich jetzt an die Oma ganz okay.
Ja das kann man schon mal machen.
Deswegen bewerbe ich mich dann auch als Kanzlerin.
Wär ja auch unsinnig jetzt irgendwie die ganzen Briefköpfe und so zu ändern dass er Quatsch.
Zur letzten Sendung gab es ja noch einen kurzen Hinweis über unsere Ausführungen zum digitalpakt von Teddy der einfach feststellt die Gelder welche von dem digital-paket,
digitalpakt packt oder verpackt ne bereitgestellt werden sind sowohl für Infrastruktur
als auch für Fortbildung für Lehrkräfte gedacht da bewerben dass ein bisschen dargestellt dass es hier ausschließlich darum ging ich erinnere mich dass es am Anfang der Diskussion auch wissentlich in das macht gut Fortbildung okay alles klar aber letzten Endes müssen sich natürlich hier auf größere,
Personal Decken alles erstrecken sofern fühlen wir uns hier kommentiert.
Korrigiert aber im Kern immer noch der richtigen Seite ja dann war wieder brexit.
Ist er hat doch jetzt eher Misstrauensvotum überstanden.
Ja also sollen wir vielleicht mal kurz nach Reihenfolge weil es relativ viel passiert in einer Woche,
erst knallte nämlich die Nachricht rein was ich vorher abzeichnete weil der Generalstaatsanwaltschaft schon in RAL Staatsanwalt des Europäischen Gerichtshofs schon
diese Feststellung gemacht hat als diese Einschätzung abgeliefert hat und der hat sich dann das Gericht das LG h angeschlossen nämlich,
das Großbritannien im Prinzip der Weg offensteht diesen von Ihnen selbst eingeleiteten Artikel 50 Prozess als den Austritt aus der EU unilateral abzubrechen,
heißt wenn sie wollten könnten sie einfach sagen ja haha war alles nur Spaß wir bleiben dann trotzdem und dann ist es so und dann kann er auch die EU nichts dagegen tun bzw muss diesen Prozess nicht
zustimmen im Falle einer Verlängerung die auch gerade noch einen Teil der Diskussion ist ist das wohl nicht so.
Interessanterweise kann natürlich deine Diskussion auf ob der da nicht auch an Missbrauch möglich ist kann er ist ja jeder kommen und irgendsoein Austrittsstellen das im letzten Moment dann wieder fallen lassen,
naja schaut euch mal an was aus Großbritannien so geworden ist in letzten zwei Jahren ich glaube die das war jetzt nicht unbedingt gerade eine Blaupause wo die alle schneller kopieren wollen also das ist,
so oder so selbst wenn sie jetzt in der EU verbleiben,
der Schaden ist da und der Schaden ist langfristig also was sie jetzt schon an Abwanderungen haben und an währungs einbußungen Einbußen EZ,
tippe sich keiner öffne mal ganz von der zerstörten,
Diskussionskultur innerhalb des Landes mal abgesehen und einer Spaltung die noch lange nachhallen wird.
Die zieht sich nämlich dann auch weiter erinnern uns die aktuelle Situation ist ja die es gibt den sogenannten Deal also die Einigung die Großbritannien,
bzw Premierministerin Theresa May mit dem also die Regierung mit der EU gefunden hat die EU hat dem zugestimmt.
Jetzt musst du sozusagen nur noch UK zustimmen nur findet sich halt wie hier auch schon vorausgesagt keine Mehrheit,
und das wurde jetzt so evident,
dass die Abstimmung die jetzt eigentlich am 11.12 also gestern stattfinden sollte nicht stattgefunden hat sondern verschoben wurde.
Das wiederum hat dazu geführt dass die Hardcore brexit Fraktion der Tories,
ein Misstrauensvotum eingeleitet hat das hat sich schon länger abgezeichnet schon vor ein paar Wochen an die angefangen großspurig,
Zettelchen zu hinterlegen das ist so ein skurriler britischer Prozess innerhalb der Tory Party es handelt sich hier nicht um eine parlamentarisches Misstrauensvotum sondern eine Partei internes Misstrauensvotum,
nach Torri Regeln und wenn dann halt 48,
Mitglieder der Tory Fraktion bei so einem zuständigen einen entsprechenden Brief hinterlassen,
innerhalb einer bestimmten Zeit dann kommt es zu einem internen Misstrauensvotum,
dieses hat Theresa May dann gewonnen mit 200 zu 117 stimmen würde man ja sagen alles super,
ist es insofern sie auch als dass sie jetzt erstmal Premiere Ministerin und entsprechende Fraktionschefin bleibt und das auch für die nächsten zwölf Monate auf jeden Fall bleiben wird weil ein weiteres Misstrauensvotum ist in diesem Zeitraum nicht mehr möglich.
Aber es wird natürlich jetzt viel darüber debattiert ob das nun wirklich eine nennenswerte Zustimmung ist 200 Zone 17R Seat halt nicht mal,
nicht mal zwei Drittel der Tories hinter sich versammeln können dieser Mitglieder,
das lustige Diskussion war dann halt solche Vollhonk wie dieser Jacob rees-mogg das ist so wirklich so ein Typ den man auf den ganzen Tag nur aufzeigen möchte
Kontakt zu also ja und jetzt muss ja trotzdem zurücktreten weil sie hat ja nur 62% Unterstützung,
wohlgemerkt ist der Typ der die ganze Zeit erzählt dass ein Votum was zu 52% für den EU-Austritt gestimmt hat irgendwie eine unfaire
wahre Meinung ist die Wanze auf gar keinen Fall anfechten da ja also da sieht man schön wie kaputt die ganze Diskussion ist.
Der wird mit zweierlei Prozent.
Allerdings heute
was ist denn jetzt nun und alle sagen Sonja lass mal abstimmen hier damit wir dich mal durchfallen lassen können aber so Theresa May sagt so anhöre mir noch Zeit
hatte auch weil das ganze muss aus Gründen ich jetzt nicht genau kenne bis zum 21 Januar war dann tatsächlich mal abgeschlossen sein das ist so die die nächste Deadline die jetzt im Raum steht aber die würden sich dann wohl auch nehmen
und das natürlich würde ich jetzt ganz irre finde weil sie sich natürlich jetzt dadurch also,
das ist derzeit nicht absehbar wie sie einen eine Mehrheit bekommen will und man kann jetzt eigentlich nur vermuten dass ihre Strategie die ist dass sie jetzt sozusagen noch mehr Zeit verstreichen lässt,
bis es ja dann sozusagen vor Ultimo ist wir haben dann noch acht Wochen bis zum offiziellen Austritt so nach dem Motto,
my dealornodeal so oder nach mir die Sintflut ja also entweder stimmt jetzt mal hier dafür dann gibt's hier brexit und may times,
oder ihr seid alle Schuld dafür dass daran dass Großbritannien,
ja in den Untergang fährt was ist dann auch definitiv tun würde weil das hat sich jetzt mittlerweile schon bei einen Abgeordneten rumgesprochen es merkt man so richtig wenn das ist jetzt eigentlich gar keine Diskussion niemand will no deal.
Ist auch gut so weil das wäre wirklich also das wäre wirklich die die die wortwörtliche Vollkatastrophe nicht so ja theoretisch und
kann man auch anders sehen oder so sondern dann ist halt wirklich erstmal vorbei mit dem Vereinigten Königreich zwar nicht nur mit dem Verbund soll halt mit der Wirtschaft im Agrarsektor an sollte das würden sie nicht überleben also das ist einfach,
diesen Zustand will keiner
aber Teresa Mail ist es wird halt darauf hinauslaufen lassen das als einzige Option zu haben und das ist meine Interpretation warum sie das jetzt so,
machen durch das wird natürlich der Widerstand größer sein und die sollte werde über Weihnachten jetzt auch nicht gerade besonders ruhig schlafen können,
Briten sind auch überhaupt ein mega genervt und alles entscheidet sich jetzt eigentlich nur da dran ob die öffentliche Meinung,
so sehr in Richtung people's Boot eskaliert wo es auf filipovice gibt die dafür sind oder nicht,
und da was so kommt ne also ich würd sagen.
Wahrscheinlichkeit dass Britannien in der EU verbleibt ist jetzt nicht unbedingt gestiegen durch diese Sache aber.
Das heißt meine 5 €.
Du könntest die wir noch zurück kriegen aber.
Wär schon nicht schlecht wenn ich dir zurück kriege.
Wir würden hier wird noch viel eskalieren also wir werden noch eine Menge hier.
Willst du mir jetzt drohen.
Nicht hier im,
castle in die sagt in dieser Auseinandersetzung und es ist derzeit halt noch nicht so richtig zu sagen was eigentlich die Briten Chile natürlich jetzt so nach Frankreich,
so wie die Franzosen dazu machen,
ja hier unzufrieden scheiß Gesetz keine Kohle lass mal 1000 Autos anzünden und irgendwie Arc de Triumph abschlachten und überhaupt Revolution und auf die Barrikaden und mich zu Fritz Fon weiszumachen ja immer gleich immer feste druff
David.
Nein also bevor der Britta auf die Straße geht und dann Molotow-Cocktail die Hand nimmt und so weiter hat damit kannst du das vorstellen dass er dann fast wie banjapark die müssen sich ja erstmal die ganze Zeit.
Die mit der Liga die wird ja die ganze Zeit nur sorry sagen ja du weißt doch wie das ist they say sorry a lot das ist einfach
der gemeine Britta muss ich die ganze Zeit für alles was in der unter einer Form einer Unannehmlichkeit für jemanden darstellen könnte entschuldigen und ich glaube dass sie soviel sorry sagen würden
das überhaupt keine Rechte zum protestieren, also so so so right on the street das ist einfach nicht ihr Ding das machen sie halt anders und.
Dafür haben die haben die in ihren Parlaments Diskussion aber ein benehmen wie eine offene Hose ne.
Das wusste ich wie es da abgeht ne aber das ist aber auch alles aber es ist halt alles stark protokolliert ist ja auch geil hat ja so ein Lehrer abgeordnet hat den Stöpsel gezogen der letzten Sitzung Unterkünfte in die Mitte gegangen und da liegt da so ein Zepter so ein goldenes z,
Queens und es gibt eine Regel nur wenn dieses Zepter da auch,
Oberhaupt auch irgendwas entschieden wird oder einfach hingegangen und hat sie abgenommen,
soll es war wirklich so ja sorry aber die hier Video läuft geht irgendwie gar nichts mehr gemacht hat scheiß sevdaya wegnehmen,
und das ist aber für Britische Verhältnisse ist das dann schon wieder sehr.
Sich auf den nicht auf den Rasen getreten sondern mit dem Flug drübergefahren Sonne.
Bisschen.
Das ist.
Apollo wird einfach mal das Zepter der Königin nach Washington und weil es einfach alles nicht mehr zu ertragen ist es sehr interessant und,
ich habe so ein Gefühl aber mein Gefühl ist halt auch wirklich nur so ein Gefühl und ich bin aber nicht kein Kenner der britischen Politik ehrlich gesagt habe ich das jetzt alles erstmal an sein ganzen brexit Geschichte überhaupt erstmal so ein bisschen besser verstanden aber.
So oder so wird diese ganze Geschichte Folgen haben für die Innenpolitik und ich kann mir ehrlich gesagt nicht vorstellen dass das disertori Leber Zustand,
noch länger toleriert wird also kann durchaus sein dass es entweder zu Parteien Spaltung kommt bzw Randparteien noch sehr viel mehr Zuspruch bekommen,
weil die sich teilweise hervorragend geben,
also diese libery Demokratie haben's immer noch ein bisschen schwer weil die waren ja in der Regierung mit den Tories unter die Räder gekommen
aber so die Scottish National Party z.b. mit ihrer Führerin der sind Nicola sturgeon die die macht wirklich so den Eindruck als ob sie für dich noch die die die
die einzigen an diesem Irrenhaus ist die irgendwie klar denken kann
allerdings noch flankiert von der einzigen grünen Abgeordneten im britischen Parlament die auch,
Caroline Lukas die auch hervorragende statement
von sich gibt und sehr sehr sehr klares wetteransagen macht so das wären eigentlich so die wahren Führer die Großbritannien mal gebrauchen könnte aber der Rest ist einfach komplett zu mit dem Fall brauchen es ist für dich ein Zustand
also das geht einfach gar nicht die kümmern sich auch nicht im Wesentlichen alle auch nur um sich selber anders was für Britannien und Europa dabei rauskommen interessiert.
Die da oben.
Ja oben ja also so geht besten sowas wird es ja nicht geben aber es wird irgendwie auf eine britische Art und Weise wird es schon irgendeine Antwort geben.
Ja wir verlinken dann außerdem noch auf dieses wunderschöne video von einem britischen Schauspieler Andy Serkis der sich wie alt Theresa May in einen Gollum
verwandelt unsere Wege der Gollum sein Ring sein precious Ring anbetet so geht es darum.
Sie selber ist ja eigentlich nur im Inneren gewesen ne.
Sie ist einfach eine Ausländer hasserin das kann man nicht anders sagen sie ist einfach diejenige die in den letzten Jahren eine Migration feindliche Politik
in Großbritannien durchgesetzt hat in dieser Regierung das war so ihre Hauptaufgabe und Silvana Ausländerhasser drin und dann
Susi der brexit einfach ein super Ding das durchzubringen ging ja irgendwie alles gegen Ausländer ist irgendwie ganz vorn dabei.
Da kann man mal so festhalten,
premena du was gibt's da irgendwie gar nicht bei den Tor ist es einfach es geht nur um die Tore ist geht nur nur mir eigene Macht,
die haben keine Visionen.
Ist es aber natürlich nicht nur in Großbritannien sondern auch in Deutschland.
Wir haben.
Vor einigen Wochen der uns bei Logbuch Netzpolitik immer mal wieder erwähnt diese Veröffentlichung der cum-ex files gehabt worum geht's eine Methode 7 sich.
Anleger.
Steuern erstatten lassen haben die sie nie entrichtet haben,
geht glaube ich im spezifisch um die Abgeltungssteuer beim Verkauf von,
von Aktienpaket in die haben den ihrem etwas komplexeren concept sich aber Gillian,
und dann irgendwie den Verkauf gemacht sodass sie dann nachher zwei Steuerbescheinigungen hatten und dann konnten sie aber,
beide oder anderen beide eingereicht und sich irgendwie das Geld erstatten lassen,
eigentlich nie bezahlt wurde ja das ist nicht nur nicht nur so ein immer noch in Deutschland ja verrückterweise als,
Gentleman Delikt geltendes ja ein bisschen steuerhinterzogen na wer wird denn da schon
Wer wird denn da schon allzu genau drauf schon sondern das ist ein Diebstahl ja die haben sich die haben sich an den Staat Gewand und haben gesagt hallo bitte einmal diesen Betrag überweisen und in haben die überwiesen bekommen,
und definierte sich daneben nach der Recherchen nach den Recherchen auf ein.
Auf eine Gesamtsumme von 55 Milliarden Euro die in Europa,
gestohlen wurden an Steuereinnahmen die der Staat sonst jedem Start zustanden ZW die der Staat eingesammelt hatte und die dann von Kriminellen,
weil sie dem Staat weggenommen wurden das ist jetzt das ist also Geld das andere Steuerpflichtige
geleistet hatten um damit was weiß ich Kitas Krankenhäuser Bildungseinrichtung Straßen von mir aus auch Funkzellen in kleßen-görne nein keine Angst kleßen-görne wir lassen Villach,
zu errichten.
So ungefähr einer der größten Skandale überhaupt auf jeden Fall der größte in diesem in diesem Bereich.
Da muss jetzt was passieren ne dann müssten muss jetzt mal muss ermittelt werden,
da müssen Leute angeklagt werden und sehr natürlich z.b. auch schön wenn die Täter verfolgt würden und dass Oma sich das Geld vielleicht sogar zurück holen würde.
Mir scheint aber noch nicht passiert zu sein.
Nee doch doch doch doch doch da wird jetzt ermittelt und zwar von der Staatsanwaltschaft Hamburg wegen des Verdachts der Anstiftung zum Verrat von Geschäftsgeheimnissen,
und sag gegen den Chefredakteur des recherchenetzwerk correctiv Oliver schröm.
Also das recherchenetzwerk was die cum-ex falls rausgebracht hat spricht diese ganze Recherche.
Die die die die haben den gern den Skandal aufgedeckt dass in Europa 55 Milliarden Euro von Kriminellen gestohlen wurden,
und gegen sie wird gegen das gegen den Chefredakteur wird jetzt ermittelt nach Paragraph 17 UWG Gesetz gegen den unlauteren Wettbewerb.
Das erste Mal dass dieser Paragraph auf einen Journalisten angewendet wird.
Absolut scourie also im Anstiftung zum Verrat von Geschäfts und Betriebsgeheimnissen.
Auf wessen Initiative hin ist diese Anklage zustande gekommen also hat das dann die Staatsanwaltschaft selber.
Nee die Hamburger Ermittler stützen sich auf einen gesucht der Schweizer Behörden die aufgrund einer Anzeige der Schweizer Bank Sarasin,
tätig wurden und diese Bank sarasinee all ist tief in diesem in diesem,
Hinterwirth Dieb Diebstahl Masche verstrickt.
Shoot the messenger.
Krasnodar und die sagen ja der Oliver schröm habe Mitarbeiter dieser Bank dazu angestiftet.
Diese cum-ex-geschäfte öffentlich zu machen und das sei ja jetzt eine Verletzung des Bankgeheimnisses.
Das ist so geil hast eine kriminelle Bank und dieser versucht mich FI deshalb aber jetzt nicht so ausgemacht ne das war ja ein Bankgeheimnis dass wir dass wir hier kriminelle Betrügereien machen.
Sorry ist ein Geschäftsgeheimnis überlegen Sie mal wie sie uns damit geschadet haben dass sie hier unsere geheimen illegalen Maschen veröffentlicht haben will,
das geht ja so nicht.
Türkei wenn man da der Polizei später auch noch mal vorwerfen palantir.
Meine Privatsphäre ja auszuleuchten nur weil ich irgendwie eine Bank überfallen habe haben sie noch alle.
Unglaublich.
Nicht verklagt sie das ist wirklich krass.
Das ist schon echt krass wie es überhaupt dazu kommen kann und ich bin ich mal gespannt wie der die Politik auf schreit wenn überhaupt weil bisher habe ich so den Eindruck kann diese ganzen Comex Geschichte einfach noch nicht die Welle bekomme ich meine man hätte da ein Prinzip auch schon mal.
Über Verantwortlichkeiten mehr diskutieren müssen wie es denn überhaupt sein kann dass diese Geschäft überhaupt noch möglich waren weil das ist jetzt auch nicht so erst dieses Jahr rausgekommen oder es wird auch nicht schon seit vielen Jahren diskutiert und,
irgendwie ist die ganze Dimension des Betrugs halt jetzt erst durch Korrektiv so richtig klar geworden vorher wurde das soweit ich das weiß nur vermutet oder war ansatzweise bekannt,
aber hier handelt es Sicherheit wirklich um einen milliardenraub.
Der größte steuerraub.
Unglaublich und diese Idee des Geschäftsgeheimnisses da geht's ja noch weiter das ganze fühlt sich jetzt auch in einen politischen Rahmen der weitgehend unbemerkt seit,
in diesem Jahr so vorangeschritten ist und zwar das Gesetz zum Schutz des Geschäftsgeheimnisses.
Und.
Wenn man sich da mal wenn man sich das anschaut da gibt es schon seit längerer Zeit Anfang des Jahres einen Gesetzesentwurf der daneben vom Ministerium diskutiert wurde zur Umsetzung der EU-Richtlinie 2016
94.3
die den im Juni 2016 diese richtige entschieden haben und der wurde auch schon im Mai,
der Referentenentwurf diskutiert da haben dann unterschiedliche Verbände Zustellung genommen und.
Weites Feld.
Wichtig ist daran aber dass die Inhaber von Geschäftsgeheimnissen in Zukunft nach diesem Gesetz kein berechtigtes Interesse an der Geheimhaltung mehr nachweisen müssen,
das bedeutet es ist effektiv erstmal alles ein Geschäftsgeheimnis.
Und alles auch fällt unter diesen Schutz des Gesetzes mit anderen Worten ist strafbar.
Und da wenden sich alle quasi gegen insbesondere hier der der DGB und also
sehr sehr viele warnen davor es gibt natürlich auch mein Sohn unter den Experten die sich dazu äußern findest du natürlich dann auch die gesamte Industrie dir sagt ja das ist ja schön das super mach mal.
Und das wird noch an vielen anderen Stellen Probleme machen nicht nur.
Was den Journalismus anbetrifft auch was Mitarbeiterinnen und Mitarbeiter und deren Rechte und Pflichten angeht.
Whistleblower und auch was Forschung,
und sowas angeht ja also wenn du jetzt irgendwie Geräte Reverse-Engineering möchtest Treiber für Teile schreiben möchtest und irgendwie im Internet eine
Dokumentation geliebt findest die das Unternehmen nicht veröffentlicht,
wissen wollte ja dann wäre das jetzt unter heutigen Standpunkt eben,
nun ja irgendein Dokument was da irgendwie veröffentlicht wurde auf dem aber nicht groß drauf steht confidential oder so er jetzt bist du aber unter Umständen ist das dann ein Geschäftsgeheimnis
Veröffentlichung illegal war und dessen Nutzungen und Anwendung dann auch für dich illegal ist.
Wirklich keine besonders gute Idee was wir da wieder am Horizont haben und das werden wir auf dem,
Radar behalten und darüber in Zukunft noch mal genauer Bericht.
Gelbe Seiten vielleicht auch noch mal schauen was ich nämlich jetzt noch nicht so ganz verstanden habe ist inwiefern setzt die Bundesregierung hier wirklich eins zu eins die Richtlinie um.
Natürlich nicht die gehen ja immer drüber hinaus.
Goldend inwiefern ist sozusagen ist diese Richtlinie vielleicht auch noch in erträgliches recht
umsetzbar oder ist der Zug nicht schon längst abgefahren 2016 als diese Richtlinie.
Ja so mit den Geheimnissen und der Öffentlichkeit ist das ja immer so eine Sache da haben wir auch noch so einen besonderen Fall der so ein bisschen unter dem Radar der Öffentlichkeit seit gut,
10 Jahren 12 Jahren genau zu sein abgelaufen ist 2016,
nämlich der bundesanzeiger-verlag vormals eine Station Richtung privatisiert worden,
und ist seitdem meine Tochter des Kölner Medienkonzerns Dumont warum sollte einen das betreffen na ja,
deutsche Gesetze die hier vom Bundestag beschlossen und vom Bundesrat abgesegnet werden vom Bundespräsident,
unterschrieben werden sind dann noch nicht sofort gültig sondern müssen erst im Bundesgesetzblatt veröffentlicht werden,
dieses zu veröffentlichen in gedruckter Form ist aber das alleinige Privileg eben jenes verlageste bundesanzeiger-verlag gibt also diese bundesgesetzblätter
heraus und wenn man die dann haben will dann muss man da ein kostenpflichtiges Abo abschließen,
voll günstig 85 € pro Halbjahr für die gedruckte Fassung meine 99 € zahlt Chris auch noch in seiner Form die digitale Variante,
und für nur 24 € zusätzlich gibt es auch noch eine E-Mail Benachrichtigung über neu veröffentlichte Gesetze.
Das könnte fast den character Preis von SMS noch übertreffen.
Und da gehört schon einiges dazu.
Diese das ist für für alle Gesetze die wir.
Eine Gesetzesänderung.
Also neue Gesetze wie auch Änderung von bestehenden Gesetzen die müssen halt im als Bundesgesetzblatt rausgebracht werden das tut dieser Verlag und erst wenn das veröffentlicht wurde dort veröffentlicht wurde ist es gültig dann heißt auch der Zeitpunkt ist entscheidend.
Deshalb vor allem wäre super der den das Ding einfach zu kaufen und dann darfst du erst auf wenn wir kaufen diesen Verlag der Wissens nicht gefällt wird einfach nicht veröffentlicht.
Aber du überhaupt nichts mehr veröffentlicht Stimmen QTTR.
Das ist ja wohl dann teil und der Freiheit unserer Redaktion auch mein Beitrag abzulehnen.
Genau und wenn uns jemand kontaktieren will jemand meine Adresse in kleßen-görne an da kommt ja keiner hin wegen der Giftpfeile.
Beschicken wir wir haben das Quiz redigiert das ist noch nicht durch Lektorat.
Aber so ganz so digital ist es nun nicht kostenloser Online-Zugang existiert tatsächlich,
bittet aber keine Suchfunktion PDF können nicht ausgedruckt werden und dürfen auch offiziell nicht weiter verarbeitet werden louis hat auch das Bundesjustizministerium ein eigenes Online Portal für Gesetze,
da kann man tatsächlich alle Gesetze Nachschlagen Problem ist nur dort gibt's nicht die Gesetzesänderungen also nicht die Diffs sondern immer nur die aktuell gültigen Gesetze also kann es halt Nachschlagen wie ist,
ein bestimmtes Gesetz jetzt und dann hast du da den Wortlaut aber du kriegst halt nicht dieses
Paragraph 30 Absatz 4 wurde folgendes Wort in folgendes Wort geändert was er sagen Sie es eigentlich im Fleisch der ganzen Sache ist,
naja.
Diese Seite gesetze-im-internet ist tatsächlich vom Bundesministerium der Justiz das ist ja geil das weiß schon immer so eine peinliche Domain ja stell dir mal vor wir würden alle in unsere Domains noch mal mit rein schreiben im Internet,
Zähne sind ganz beknackte Angabe.
Netzpolitik im Internet.
Politik - im internet.de nur damit man auch weiß was im Internet ist.
Naja.
Linus - Neumann - im Internet. Net.
Das ist wie früher jetzt auch auf CD.
Ja oder online online immerhin aber im Internet bitte.
Ja solltet mal schauen vielleicht bringen wir auf unser Podcast auch nochmalige gedruckte Fassung raus für 84 €.
Vielleicht kann der Bundes bundesverlag Bundesanzeiger Verlag.
Naja wie auch immer auf jeden Fall für solche Fälle haben wir ja unsere Super Heroes vom Dienst in diesem Fall in Form Open knowledge Foundation die ein Projekt gestartet hat offene Gesetze
ohne Gesetze. De und dort ist ein Portal und was findet man dort alle gesetzesblätter in ja,
im Fall digitalen Zugang man kann dort alle möglichen
Gesetzesänderung genauso herunterladen PDF können runtergeladen werden können dann aber auch ausgedruckt werden können uneingeschränkt weitergegeben werden etc,
unten ja volltextsuche
Download RSS-Feeds die man sich abonnieren kann wo dann jedes neue Liste gesetzt stattfindet Programmierschnittstellen um darauf zuzugreifen alles kostenlos als gemeinnützig,
und wieso haben die denn das jetzt gemacht wenn,
doch der bundesanzeiger-verlag hier eigentlich den exklusiven Zugang bekommen hat das Privileg von der Bundesregierung.
Stellt sich raus,
mit der Methode scheiß drauf macht es einfach trotzdem sollen wir uns doch verklagen das sind die wohl irgendwie dann auch eher so als einen wertvollen move an soll der denn das stattfinden
denn dann diese sicher den doch mal das ein oder andere klären sind zugehören der Bundesanzeiger Verlag übrigens beruft er diese Exklusivität auch darauf
alle auch auf das Urheberrecht ja was ganz lustiges bei Gesetzen wo man sich so denkt so meint jetzt Gesetze Parlament Urheberrecht irgendwie.
Das haben wir bezahlt die scheiß haben wir bezahlt das haben wir zwar nicht bestellt aber das haben wir bezahlt.
Ja aber das Urheberrecht hat ja immer noch einen passenden Paragraphen und Halmes mittels den Tag zu versauen in dem Fall der sogenannte datenbankschutz der halt systematische Sammlungen von Werken auch explizit schützt also selbst finde öffentliches Material nimmst was nicht urheberrechtlich Dir oder anderen anhängt
Bild nur die systematische Sammlung dessen und die entsprechend Zugänglichmachung.
Ist dann auch schon wieder ein urheberrechtlicher move und deswegen durfte man da ja dann nicht so einfach und überhaupt so wie sie kommen dir denn die jungen Leute denn jetzt dazu hier so ein dünne Kind zu machen also,
offene Gesetze,
bittet jetzt alle Dokumente anderes geht also bewusst hier eine Abmahnung und die Rechtmäßigkeit der Zugangsbeschränkung vor Gericht klären zu lassen wie sie meint und ja.
Es gibt aber ist auch okay hat auch mal diesen Vertrag zwischen der Bundesregierung und dem bundesanzeiger-verlag
Informationsfreiheitsgesetz vermutlich mal raus kitzelt der kam dann auch war aber weitgehend geschwärzt,
uni so ganz klar war was jetzt da schon wieder Phase ist aber immerhin,
Geschäftsgeheimnisse genau also wir wieder beim Thema und,
immerhin ließ sich aber dann auch diesen Vertrag die Formulierung entnehmen dass das Bundesjustizministerium künftig gedenkt und das wohl auch noch innerhalb dieser Legislaturperiode ein elektronischen Zugang zu den Gesetzen von Dritten,
durchführen zu lassen ob das dann sozialen beabsichtigt ist das mit den bundesanzeiger-verlag zu machen oder ob sie sich dann wieder noch mal nen anderen Partner suchen,
na bis man nicht aber das okf macht es halt einfach jetzt schon mal im Voraus einen Gehorsam selbst
was ich für eine tolle Aktion halte auf eine Gesetze. De dort könnt ihr euch also RSS-Feeds z.b. abonnieren und überhaupt alles suchen Nachschlagen Gesetzesänderung
runterladen die PDF runterladen die PDF durchsucht sind durchsuchbar sind irgendwie ordentlich nicht nur gescannt sondern halt auch mit sprechender Texterkennung oder wie auch immer sie es gemacht haben,
ausgestattet toll Aktion.
Johannes Filter Arne semsrott und Stefan Wehrmeyer die wissen sehr schönes Feature haben wir in ihrer Kontaktseite ich dachte sie stand doch gerade in anderer Reihenfolge bei jedem pageload sortieren die den Namen neu random mäßig Wiese,
das ist das ist sehr schön dass wir finde ich eine elegante Methode damit umzugehen dass.
Die Reihenfolge immer problematisches.
Ja also Stefan Wehrmeyer eine semsrott hier weil opponents Boutique ja beide schon mal vertreten gewesen weil Thomas hinten.
Johannes Filter hat sich hier auf die.
Mal rein was könnte aus dem Deckname sein ne Johannes Filter klingt ja für dich dich.
Ist geklickt Verdächtiger.
Wollt ihr alles nur machen sie Fame von sich abzuleiten gibt's wirklich sehr schön.
Ja den gibt's gibt's ja lass Dich gibt's zumindest Johannes Filter Minus im Internet.
Nein aber warum steht eigentlich dieses offene Gesetze de der steht auch nicht dran dass es im Internet ist offene gesetze-im-internet.
Finde gut mehr so sanfter Terrorismus ist immer wichtig,
Terrorismus eine wunderbare Überraschung,
Terrorismus beschäftigt die EU ja fortwährend auch wenn es eigentlich sich um ein rückläufiges Phänomen handelt wir haben in den Jahrzehnten zuvor sehr viel mehr,
Terror gehabt als jetzt aber das heißt natürlich nicht für die EU das man nicht doch eine ganze Reihe.
An weiteren Gesetzes Maßnahmen braucht um diesen fürchterlichen Terror endlich ein Ende zu bereiten und zwar gibt es da den,
Abschlussbericht des Anti Terror Sonderausschuss ist der jetzt mit einer breiten Mehrheit abgesegnet wurde das war an der Anti Terror Sonderausschuss waren 30 parlamentaria die einen.
Maßnahmenkatalog und Empfehlungen entwickelt haben und das ist im Prinzip das was quasi mal sagen kann dass uns jetzt offenbar die nächsten Jahre beschäftigen,
wird insbesondere.
Hätten sie gerne dass die EU-Kommission prüft inwiefern Dienste wie WhatsApp oder Signal also ende-zu-ende verschlüsselt im Messenger in die Pflicht genommen wär
dass sie verschlüsselte Nachrichten in irgendeiner Form veröffentlichen müssen ja so dass sie den Zugriff darauf ermöglichen müssen.
Wir erinnern uns die Idee von Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung ist die Nachricht wird auf dem Gerät des,
absenden auf dem Absenden Gerät verschlüsselt und auf dem empfangenden Gerät entschlüsselt und in der Mitte wird sie weitergeleitet ist aber für alles was an dieser Weiterleitung beteiligt ist nicht lesbar.
Und das heißt man kann da keine zentrale abhör Schnittstelle einsetzen und das ärgert,
die Strafverfolgungsbehörden deswegen Trojan isieren sie die Geräte wollen also Staatstrojaner zum Einsatz bringen und hier jetzt eben auch,
diese Sicherheit der Kommunikation in irgendeiner Form kaputtmachen ähnlich wie wir es ja auch in Australien
kürzlich schon gesehen haben dass es beschlossen wurde ich bin mal gespannt wie sie diese diese das Erzwingen möchte.
Außerdem am Horizont.
Upload-filter die wir ja ohnehin im Urheberrechts Bereich schon diskutieren.
Parallel in gleicher Form für Terror.
Terroristische Online-Inhalte sollen begrenzt werden mit Hilfe von automatischer Erkennung,
auf die dann eine systematische schnelle dauerhafte unvollständige Entfernung folgen sollen.
Die reden davon einer Datenbank des globalen Internetforum zur Terrorismus,
Bekämpfung in dem Facebook Twitter und YouTube Fingerprint von terroristisch markierten Inhalten speichern also die haben das quasi schon.
Umso ein erneutes Hochladen und veröffentlichen zu unterbinden.
Sie wollen außerdem einen Löschfrist von einer Stunde haben,
und Geldstrafen von bis zu 4 % ist jährlich den weltweiten Umsatz ist das ist echt blöd wenn du ein kleines Blog bist oder so ne und dann aufeinmal du einen terroristischen Inhalt in deiner in deiner Seite findest
und dem deswegen mit einem upload-filter begegnen musst und hier ist wieder das Problem,
upload-filter selbst die besten die es gibt sind notorisch unzuverlässig und,
werden im Zweifelsfall wenn sie mit höheren Strafen verbunden sind in Zweifel mehr löschen als,
gedacht ist einfach nur dass man weil man natürlich diese hohen Strafen unbedingt,
umgehen möchte zweitens können sie nur von den großen unterhalten werden das bedeutet,
wie werden die Datenbank fingen die werden die zentrale Stelle zum Löschen von Inhalten sein und wieder so ist es eigentlich völlig egal ob wir die Urheberrechts,
Upload Filter oder die Terror upload-filter verhindern vielleicht schaffen wir es ja bei dem Urheberrecht.
Dann würde es im Zweifelsfall über diese Terror Richtlinie trotzdem kommen und wenn du dann nämlich die Wände die Filter einmal da hast dann werden sie natürlich auch ausgeweitet ne also wir kennen ist ja nun mal langsam aus unserer Erfahrung das Gesetze,
begründet mit Terrorismusabwehr Einzug erhalten,
und dann diese Grundrechtseinschränkungen die durch die Gesetze ermöglicht wurde immer weiter ausgeweitet wird das letzte Beispiel sind genau die Staatstrojaner,
TÜV über einem Jahrzehnt eingeführt wurden zur Terrorismusbekämpfung und jetzt gerade hier in den in die normalen Polizeigesetze der Länder für Alltagskriminalität Einzug erhalten.
Außerdem wollte noch ein europaweit ins Register für Hassprediger,
und einen verbesserten Informationsaustausch zwischen Polizei und Geheimdiensten wie immer also da musst du dich dann halt registrieren als Hassprediger Tim.
Ich dachte jetzt gerade an unser Innenminister.
Den könnte man auch mal registriert.
Es ist spannend wie die immer wieder noch mal was Neues finden.
Man hat ja irgendwie den Eindruck dass man diesen Kampf mit der Überwachung langsam und den und den Grundrechtseinschränkungen langsam verloren hätte aber es gibt dir heute noch gar nicht verloren gibt immer noch mal noch mehr.
Noch Gebiete zu verlieren an die wir noch gar nicht gedacht habe.
Es geht doch gerne,
ja das ist schon sehr diese Maßnahmen sind erschreckend ne ablauffilter also ein Filter vor der Veröffentlichung automatisierte Erkennung das ist echt nichts was du haben willst.
Das ist echt Problem dann ist er noch in den Händen der großen zentralen Konzerne,
das heißt die kleineren die sich keine eigenen Väter leisten können müssen den falls Ihre Inhalte zu spielen zur Anwendung des Filters.
Und die halt irgendwie die Verschlüsselung die Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung kaputt zu machen ist auch also das wird na ja das wird.
Soll ich das sagen wenn ihr das machen also wenn jetzt wirklich mal Lernzeit ist ja immer diskutiert,
immer und immer und immer und immer wieder Gabe einer meiner ersten Artikel überhaupt bei netzpolitik.org vor irgendwie 10 Jahren oder so behandelte das dass sie quasi diese Form von.
Ende-zu-Ende-Verschlüsselung irgendwie kaputt machen wollten.
Und da war das schon uraltes Thema.
Hejsano Drogendealer am Bahnhof also diese Politik des was uns nicht passt das Verdrängen wir jetzt mal in die Welt 4 bestimmte Bereiche gezielt überwachen und beliebig,
aus unserer Perspektive heraus sozusagen bedrohen terrorisieren führt halt nicht unbedingt dazu dass ich da jetzt grundsätzlich am Verhalten was ändert sein ist wird,
und im Falle des Internets ich habe das schon paar mal so für möglich gehalten,
würde auch noch nicht sagen wir sind jetzt schon da aber würde kurz oder lang.
Wird sich halt auch irgendwann noch mal so ein Splitting des Netzes selber ergeben dann wirst du dieses Darknet nicht nur so eine Randnotiz sein während sein und wie auch mit multiplen Realitäten im Datennetz zu tun haben weißt du so,
zweites Internet Subnetz wie auch immer das dann heißt.
Fliesen Görner net.
Upload nur noch in bliesen Görden.
Du dann wird sich unter Umständen diese Domain Gesetze - in - Internet nochmals besonders weitsichtig erweisen.
Zumindest wo es ist Mia in dem indem Nessaja.
Gesetze im Darknet.
Gibt es nur mit wir mit unseren Ideen.
Darknet. Onion.
Morgen auch wieder.
Und da können wir jetzt schon mal anfangen.
Wir werden noch reich.
Ja und Deutschland.
Ja macht ja bei jedem Scheiß mit jetzt auch bei den rüsten Trojaner Welle da sind jetzt ein paar Firmen.
In Deutschland einem eine Ransomware mehr oder weniger zum zum Opfer gefallen interessant ist wie diese diese Infektionen.
Passieren dass.
Also rette Verso Deprez Adresse Erpresser App.
Und diese also emotet sammelt bei seinen Opfern erstmal Informationen darüber wer in der Firma mit wem kommuniziert.
Und greift auch tatsächlich die Inhalte der Mails ab.
Damit lassen sich dann Phishing-Mails bauen die sehr an das Kommunikationsverhalten der Firma angepasst sind und mit diesem.
Serg angepassten Mails machen sie dann ihre für versenden sie dann ihre ihre Word-Dateien mit den mit den Infektionen drin.
Nicht mehr so diese klassischen dir your e-mail address zillow,
wie company from Thailand Android Import Unity click here seit wann kriegst du nicht mehr wie man sieht eklig aus dem Admin Saal kriegt und denkt sie ist Soraya irgendwie scheiße wieder password reset.
Sogar noch also so wie das hier geschildert wird in dem Artikel noch besser das wäre sitzen wie eine Mail von.
Also mit persönlicher an.
Täuschend echt von einem Arbeitskollegen mit dem du normalerweise auch regelmäßig kommunizierst.
In deinen Kontext in die eingebaut aber trotzdem automatisiert und das hat jetzt ein paar Unternehmen erwischt und.
Oder sehr viele unter wischt wischt man richtig von einer direkt einer Welle und ich würde an der Stelle eigentlich nur gerne noch mal erklären wie diese Infektionen tatsächlich funktionieren in der Regel über,
word Makros also in Microsoft Word das ja augenscheinlich erstmal ein Programm ist.
Mit dem man Textdokumente schreiben kann,
gibt es quasi eingebettet die von niemandem jemals wirklich gebrauchte oder von den wenigsten Leuten wirklich jemals gebrauchte Funktionalität in dem Word Dokument selber.
Skripte oder Programme unterzubringen diese Skripte können dann was weiß ich das Dokument schlauer machen ne dass man ihm sagt jedes Mal wenn
hier dieser Absatz geändert wird
Male eine neue Tabelle oder sowas ne dass das dass das Dokument wird quasi dynamisch und man kann dem Dokument,
im Prinzip beliebige Funktionen einprogrammieren die dann.
Durch das Dokument ausgeführt werden das heißt die Datei wird,
bisschen Einbau eines Makros zum Programm und diesen diesen Makros sind keine Grenzen gesetzt in dem was sie tun.
Und so ist es ein einfaches für also ein Marco z.b. eine Schadsoftware aus dem Internet herunterzuladen und diese,
sehr unschön wenn das passiert und deswegen sollte ehrlich gesagt wenn ihr irgendwie ein Dokument öffnet.
Und dass ein Makro drin werdet ihr ja schon von Microsoft Word,
gefragt ob ihr dieses Makro ausführen wollt mit der großen Warnung Achtung das ist gefährlich und dann sagt man ja möchte ich trotzdem dann wird es noch eins in der Regel noch ein zweites Mal erfolgt dann eine Warnung die muss man auch normal wegklicken.
Und erst dann kann man seinen Computer automatisiert infiziert und kaputt machen lass das bitte einfach sein deaktiviert die Funktion vollständig und ihr seid gegen den.
Gegen den zahlenmäßig Prävalenz isten Angriffsvektor an dieser Stelle sinnvoll geschützt ihr werdet Makros nicht brauchen.
Hatte ich das erwähnt dass ich da aus dem kleinen Artikel mal drüber geschrieben hatte können wir auch noch mal verlinken ich hatte,
Report Psychologie einen kleinen Artikel über menschliche Faktoren der IT Sicherheit geschrieben also eher so ein Überblicksartikel das ist,
habe ich das ein bisschen erklärt was soll die menschlichen Faktoren sind die man bei Angriffen ausnutzt.
Weil das da so ein bisschen ein Thema ist mit dem ich mich auseinandersetzen.
Tja nützt ja seit 25 Jahren darf ich kein Wort mehr.
Gibt's ja schon so lange.
Oder 30 ja ich fand Mal wird ganz toll also wird 30 auf das fand ich ganz geil.
Ich habe ich weiß nicht genau was meine erste word Variante war mit der ich gearbeitet habe.
Excel mein erstes Excel hieß noch multiplan Microsoft multiplan habe ich benutzt das wurde dann glaube ich jedenfalls um gehobener den Excel oder wahrscheinlich ersetzt durch Excel.
Genau stimmt aus der Zeit also 86 war wird drei damit habe ich irgendwie gearbeitet und danach vielleicht auch noch mit 4 das weiß ich so ganz genau aber ich glaube ich bin seit 30 Jahren wird frei.
Ich weiß das hilft jetzt keinem weiter und ist auch so ein bisschen so eine arrogante Grundhaltung so nach dem Motto Jürgen Visier nicht aussuchen und so ja weiß ich schade tut mir leid für euch ich konnte mir immer aussuchen und habe es mir genauso ausgesucht bin zufrieden.
Aber du willst nicht meine Wissen über andere Wege infiziert ne.
Man ist ja nicht frei von Angriffsfläche.
Aber warum sprechen wir dann hier drüber also was was an diesem Thema deshalb interessant ist weil das so ein bisschen.
Hier offenbar eine Form von
Automatisierung oder künstlicher Intelligenz oder sonstigen eingesetzt wird die es automatisiert in großer Zahl hinkriegt aber trotzdem individualisiert solche Nachrichten zu verschicken und das könnte.
Ein vorsichtiger Beginn eines echten schönen neuen,
Zeitalter sein wenn die spearfishing Techniken also gezielt mit Wissen über die Zielpersonen ein Phishing Angriff starten jetzt auch noch quasi massentauglich werden.
Das könnte für viele Cyber Sorgen.
Befehlshaber wird auch der Kongress georgen.
Wasser Wasser Song.
Fahrplan wurde ja veröffentlicht haben wir es schon gerade kurz angedeutet ja,
da könnt ihr also auch schon mal sehen was euch da so an Torx erwartet da sind noch einige klitzekleine Lücken drin wo noch letzte Abstimmungen notwendig sind bis die Vorträge dann wirklich auch im Fahrplan drin sein können.
Über einen Beispiel haben jetzt heute schon gesprochen die Sandra trostl na wir haben auch den Martin Sonneborn da,
Gitta die Falle Frage immer erst mal wer sind die Stars hat sie die großen Namen bei uns gibt's die großen Inhalte Freunde nicht die große Namen aber mit der eine oder andere bekannte Vertreterin wird.
Auf dem Kongress zu sehen sein und ihr könnt ja schon mal im Fahrplan schmökern,
für das ganz schöne Erdgas hat dazu auch dieses Video veröffentlicht Übersicht der Fahrplan über 2000 Versionen entwickelt nun will ja versuchen also es gibt ja diesen halfnarp bei dem Leute sagen können welche toksi interessieren welche Torx sie sehen wollen.
Und diese die Korrelation zwischen den Torx werden angewendet um zu versuchen dass möglichst wenige Konflikte,
der vom Entstehen dass viele Leute tot sehen wollen die gleichzeitig stattfinden.
Oder anders aus Gera Plan soll so sein dass möglichst alle kriegen wasshoi.
Das sowieso nehme zumindest also immer wenig Konflikte gering halten das geht natürlich nicht immer ganz aber wir bemühen uns das.
Halbwegs hinzukriegen und.
Da gibt's immer sehr schönes Video wo es heute in im Zeitraffer ist wie das über über 2000 Version des Fahrplans die ganze Zeit hin und her geschoben wird.
Also wenn ihr sehen wollt in welcher Fahrplan Version euer torque von sal1 in Saphir verlegt wurde,
bis der Bescheid und das ist immer ein alles ist tatsächlich ein sehr komplexes.
Es ist sehr komplexe Aufgabe und die Software die der Erdgeist dafür geschrieben hat ist das sehr hilfreich und sehr.
Interessant in der Anwendung.
Und ich weiß nicht wenn wir nächste Woche noch eine Sendung machen dann gehen wir vielleicht noch ein bisschen mehr auf den Fahrplan ein aber für heute hätte ich das glaube ich nicht unbedingt vorgesehen.
Genau schaut aber selber mal ein bisschen rein was ihr da so entdeckt und,
falls ihr erwähnenswerte Torx auch findet oder zockst die wir hier vielleicht noch mal kurz aufgreifen entschlüsseln sollen was denn damit vielleicht auf sich hat die euer Interesse geweckt haben könnt ihr das ja nicht Kommentar reinschmeißen,
noch mal ein bisschen leichter in diesem riesigen Wust an generell interessanten zeugt die Sachen raus zu picken die euch vielleicht interessieren können dann ansonsten,
auch schon mal sagen wenn er uns.
Auf dem Kongress vorbei laufen sehen sag ruhig mal hallo und ja.
Was ist man noch viel Glück wünschen,
also bin ja selber gespannt was,
was diesmal denn wieder rauskommt so ich denke wieder einmal ist viel,
Mühlen in alles geschlossen.
Wird auch teilweise auch mal bedenken wenn Dinge sich zu ändern sind und ist auch nicht immer,
unbedingt immer jetzt die vollständige Kontinuität aller beteiligten Personen gesichert da gibt's Projekte da fallen dann Leute und nach ein paar Jahren nachdem sich da aufgerieben haben auch mal raus weil sie auch einfach mal ne Pause brauchen dann werden Dinge von anderen Gruppen
oder andere Menschen übernommen die sich da dann erstmal wieder einfinden müssen
so ist das immer alles am Wanken und am schwanken aber ich glaube im Großen und Ganzen hat sich am Ende immer wieder gezeigt dass eigentlich so eine kontinuierliche Verbesserung von allem so insgesamt,
leichter Normalfall und dann hier schon ausführlich auf diese ganze Hilfe Maßnahmen gesprochen,
das wird sich dieses Jahr dann auch erst mal einfinden müssen aber auch das sicherlich eine sinnvolle Maßnahme oder sitzen ich bin einfach gespannt ich bin selber meine meine zwei Konstanten Gefühle Bezug auf den Kongressen immer man Familie hat total gespannt,
bist wohl so wird und am Ende bin ich meistens überrascht.
Das ist so ein so ein süßer die einzige Konstante ist dass ich immer irgendwas finde wo ich mir denke so damit hätte ich jetzt nicht gerechnet,
also Switch Kampka mich was an keinen Kongress erinnern denn nicht dieses Gefühl in mir erzeugt hat,
einfach wieder irgendwas sich in einem Maße weiter entwickelt hat und Aufmerksamkeit bekommen hat oder so poliert wurde oder überhaupt auch erstmal entstanden ist was ich einfach selber vorher so nicht auf den Zeiger hatte,
so wie letztes Jahr mich das einfach insgesamt überrascht hat glaube ich auch die meisten dass das überhaupt funktioniert hat an diesem statt.
Der Wind nicht so viel Vertrauen muss ja dann schon haben.
Ich hatte schon das Vertrauen dass ich das falsch formuliert also ich hatte das schon das Vertrauen dass es an sich funktioniert aber das ist,
in unserem Sinne so gut. Also das ist so gut funktioniert wie es funktioniert hat das hat mich überrascht also es hat sozusagen meine Erwartungen deutlich,
übertroffen,
Batna sehr viel sehr viel konservativen Einschätzung was was funktionieren wird was nicht funktionieren wird rangegangen.
Digger müssen auch funktionierender weil sonst funktionieren die ja nicht,
also ich bin natürlich bin ich auch sehr gespannt was so an anderen Sachen dorthin geschleppt wird der Kongress ist cool durch das was
die Menschen daraus machen spannend wird was dies hamleys da auffahren spannend wird was die noch an an Workshops scherzen,
Programmen selbstorganisierten Vorträgen und sonstigen dahin bringen und spannend der natürlich auch die,
die Vorträge das offizielle Programm und das Beisammensein des feiern,
und das Teilen von Wissen das wofür wird diese Veranstaltung ja alle besuchen.
Du es auch noch ein Wiedergänger der vielleicht erwähnenswert ist Sendezentrum bemüht sich mal wieder darum eine Podcast Bühne zu bespielen bitten von der Örtlichkeit her müssen anders sein als das
früher in Hamburg war Arbeiten einem der Seele gibt's ein Abendprogramm,
aber da noch das eine oder andere auftauchen kein Logbuch Netzpolitik um es gleich vorwegzunehmen das wäre nicht
zur machen da er die doch schon mit den Augen weil ich das auch nur an Leute.
Nee das machen wir nicht.
Aber ich werde ich werde mit einem Format vertreten sein mal was Neues und würd ich mich auch freuen wenn ihr dann,
zuschaut.
Damit ich glaubst du die kleine große Kongress Vorschau machen wir dann nächste Woche und danke schließen mit Dank.
Mein Dank gilt Henning vielen Dank Sven Hannes Thomas Matthias Björn Dirk Peter Fabian Thomas und Tim.
Aber ich habe auch zu danken nämlich Annett Manuel und Markus im Besonderen wie auch so vielen anderen die die Mütter eben unterstützen und das war's für heute tschüss.